hi my name is Magnus I with the Google
Drive team
we're gonna look at the Asus WiFi-Go
technology which allows you to interact
with your Google Drive content
from anywhere and also remotely control
your computer. Let's have a look.
People around the world manage their
files every day
share, store, email and collaborate
Do you carry it around with you?
It's no longer an option
when data is so valuable. And how do you
manage backups?
Or, a real time collaboration? Recent
research shows that forty five percent
of the web users
use cloud storage. With so many cloud
storage options available though,
transferring files around can be a
hassle and time-consuming task
How to help users manage them is an
important topic
that developers have been working on for
some time.
Our users told us that they need a way to synchronize
their stuff between different cloud services
we want to help them do all that and
even more
so we develop Cloud GO! as part of our
WiFi Go! package
to offer an integrated tool for both cloud
management and the media streaming
we want to make it easy, fast and reliable
and that's why Google Drive is our first
choice
Google Drive delivers the tool
that we need
to create a reliable integrated cloud storage
it also helps us to understand how Cloud Go!
is experienced by our users
so that we can continue with our passion
building the innovative features
and making them as good as they can
possibly be
In designing Asus software,
our goal was to make the behavior and interface
aw single and clean as possible.
Now we can see on the screen is our WiFi Go!
WiFi Go! is a free software utility
available on App Store and
Google Play
We can see on the main menu here, it
includes many remote control features
such as multi-media streaming or Remote
Desktop to remote control your PC.
Now let's have a look at Cloud Go!
so this is Cloud Go!'s main interface. On the
top are the basic functions, such as,
here you can browse and select files
to upload to storages.
Download, create folders and editing which are all
easy to use. How to sync them all across
clouds or even backup? Simply click on
the files
and select the clouds you want and tick
backup to PC
then it's all done
Here you can see the data is also
stored in your PC at the same time
overall the application aims to provide
cloud
users an integrated platform to manage, sync
and backup files from one point to
another, providing greater benefit for you
in this new cloud storage era